Once you selected a topic to read,
you'll see the original post at the top.
If the topic is a question,
you'll see a student answer and
an instructor answer here.
If the student answer has been
endorsed by an instructor,
that will also be flagged here.
Below the answers, there may be
some follow up discussions as well.
One the most useful features of piazza,
is this top nav bar.
When you open a topic
that has some updates,
this nav bar will highlight the updates,
since you last visited in pink.
You can then scroll this bar back and
forth, to see a chronological history
of what's been posted in what order.
This also helps you focus on new
content since your last visit.
>> There's one other really
useful feature on this page,
but it's kind of hidden.
If you click this star up here,
it will add a topic to your favorites.
Favorites are listed at the top of your
topic list just under your pinned posts.
This is a great way to keep track of
topics you know you're going to come
back to, or
to follow updates to topics without
subscribing to email notifications.